for spoken remains something of an
unknown quantity it's a big budget AAA
game from Square Enix with a huge scale
high quality visuals and fluid traversal
that sets it apart in the open world
action genre and it also promises a
unique setting and story that sets it
apart from most Fantasy games here is
everything you need to know about for
spoken probably the most immediate
element that distinguishes for spoken
from other Fantasy games is its story or
most notably its main character
verspoken puts you into the shoes of
Frey Holland a woman from Modern Day New
York City whose only family is a cat
named Homer now Frey grew up in orphan
on the streets of Hell's Kitchen and is
used to running away from the law fast
she's also someone who may have hit a
point of no return both internally and
with the New York legal system however
freeze soon finds herself transported to
the world of athia a Fantastical World
filled with magic dragons and mythical
Landscapes Freya also discovers that
while she's in Athea she has magical
powers and even more uniquely has the
ability to resist the break a magical
storm that most in Athea cannot survive
her ability puts her at odds with
political elements of this fantasy world
like the Council of Athea and the Tantus
former just and fair rulers of athia who
may or may not have been corrupted by
the break to become the reviled magical
Sorcerers they appear to be by the time
frame counters them phrase insecurities
continue to push her to refuse anyone's
help or to help anyone herself as she
sets out to try to escape athia on her
own the citizens of athia don't exactly
trust her either with xenophobia towards
Frey's Outsider status being a regular
issue that she'll face all in all the
game is described as being narrative
heavy for spoken is an open world third
person action-adventure game and brings
with it the trappings of the genre
you'll explore the map of Athea by
completing missions side quests and more
as you advance the game's story however
the biggest selling point of
forespoken's gameplay is centered
squarely on how you'll get around Athea
the traversal Mechanics for spoken's
movement has been favorably compared to
Insomniac Spider-Man game which itself
was highly praised for the web slingers
movement Frey will be given numerous
magical parkour abilities such as
pushing off the ground scaling walls and
moving around like a professional skater
it's all made to feel incredibly
intuitive and fluid and while requiring
finesse the mechanics will allow for
getting around the map with both ease
and satisfaction you'll also be given a
chance to upgrade your magical parkour
similarly in combat the game gives freys
several magical abilities each depicted
by different colors representing
elements you'll have ranged spells from
a standard projectile shot to more
powerful bursts to Rapid Fire you'll
also get more physical spells like a
shield harder hits and combos combat
also meshes with the parkour mechanics
enabling you to leap and run around the
battlefield with kinetic energy Magic is
upgraded by exploring the open world
collecting mana and finding equipment
that upgrades your skills which also
changes up phrase look cloaks necklaces
and even nail polish effect phrase
abilities with these being explained in
lore as printed patterns that affect
magical powers around the world you'll
have numerous chances to use your
abilities beyond the main missions
you'll encounter Brig storms which
release waves of demonic monsters that
attack you and which will end once you
defeat a boss style monster developer
luminous Productions has stated that for
spoken will be a single player only
experience so you won't get to see
double Homer the cat sadly however
publisher Square Enix has announced the
game's first substantial DLC a prequel
expansion called entanta We Trust the
DLC will focus on the backstory of the
game's mysterious tauntus former rulers
of and now matriarchal sorceresses and
athia and who appear to be the main
campaign's primary villains for now for
spoken is a PS5 console exclusive and
coming to PC so sorry Xbox and switch
players however the fine print on the
trailer states that it will only be so
for about two years because I guess
we're still doing the whole timed
exclusive thing so if you're feeling
hopeful and patient the game may come to
other platforms after the start of 2025.
while originally slated for 2022 for
spoken is now being released on January
24th 2023. before you buy the game there
is a demo available to play on the
PlayStation store so you can check it
out before you put your money down if
you just want the game itself it's being
released in physical and digital
standard editions for 69.99 physical
Edition is available for pre-order at
all of the typical retailers like
Walmart GameStop Best Buy Amazon and
Target as well as the Square Enix store
if you pre-ordered the digital Standard
Edition on the PlayStation Store you'll
also be given some unique gear and items
for the start of the game though these
items may be available for purchase in
game later on however if you want
everything Square Enix offers you can
purchase the digital deluxe edition for
94.99 the deluxe edition includes a
digital mini art book a digital mini
soundtrack the prequel DLC and Tanta We
Trust which will come with Early Access
and a rare resource kit in the game
further the same pre-order bonus items
as the digital standard edition are
available if you pre-order the deluxe
edition
well that's everything we have about the
upcoming first spoken Wild game and Frey
herself have a lot to prove it may just
find it lives up to the challenge to
find and stay up to date with forespoken
including our already released Hands-On
preview and the forthcoming review of
the game make sure you subscribe to the
channel right here on Gamespot